Silvester rund um Neukölln randalieren
junge Männer greifen Rettungskräfte und
Polizei an was hat sich seitdem
verändert wir sind sechs Monate
vergangen und das ist immer noch nichts
backgänzeriert so ein Bus brannte damals
aus was sagen Jugendliche der Gegend
deswegen im Bus was alle Leute von mir
und von uns denken das stimmt nicht wir
sind nicht alle schlecht
jeder Zweite hat den Neukölln eine
Zuwanderungsgeschichte das sind ja
unsere Jugendliche wir sind hier geboren
wir sind hier groß geworden weiterhin
Gewalt gegen polizei und Rettungskräfte
überhaupt nichts verändert die
Einsatzkräfte in Berlin werden immer
noch tagtäglich angegriffen
heideck-siedlung ein sogenannter
Problemkiez tristes Müll Armut manche
Bewohner sagen Ghetto zu Silvester
brannte hier dieser Bus
die Rußspuren am Gebäude immer noch
sichtbar
Manuel Barth erinnert sich an die
gezielten Angriffe auf Rettungskräfte
und Polizei in der Silvesternacht
manchmal seien diese regelrecht in die
Falle gelockt worden aus seiner Sicht
eine neue Dimension der Gewalt ob das
jetzt genau konkret eine Frage war das
kann ich nicht sagen wir wissen aber von
anderen Straßenecken und Kreuzungen in
Berlin das ist eben wirklich fallen
waren das ist wirklich fallen gab wo man
ganz bewusste was angezündet hat ganz
bewusst versucht hat die Feuerwehr zum
zum Anhalten zu bringen im Grunde
genommen Feuerwehrauto fährt in der
Regel nicht an einem Brennen Objekt
vorbei sondern lösch das und im Moment
wo die Kollegen ausgestiegen sind dann
halt massiv angegriffen wurden
Rettungskräfte würden weiterhin
angegriffen wird uns Bart später
erzählen vorher aber wollen wir mit den
Jugendlichen hier sprechen doch keiner
möchte vor die Kamera viele reagieren
aggressiv fühlen sich stigmatisiert
schließlich Rede doch ihr Sprecher mit
uns anonymisiert
deswegen im Bus was alle Leute von mir
und von uns denken das stimmt nicht wir
sind nicht alle schlecht nach Silvester
so ungefähr noch zwei Wochen waren jeden
Tag 50 Polizisten jeden Tag aber wir
chillen und da haben die die Bank
zugeparkt da mussten wir woanders
chillen wir lassen uns das nicht von
denen gefallen okay ist der Start aber
nur weil die Uniform haben können die
nicht so mit uns umgehen Angebote gibt
es für die über 1.500 Kinder und
Jugendlichen ihr kaum nur ein kleiner
Jugendclub die Sozialarbeiter bräuchten
dringend mehr Unterstützung und größere
Räume schon als Zeichen der
Wertschätzung nach Silvester war ihnen
auch Hilfe versprochen worden von der
damaligen Landesregierung
tatsächlich von Januar bis jetzt sechs
Monate vergangen also das ist nichts
passiert und das ist nämlich das Fatale
dabei weil bei jungen Menschen muss man
schneller gehen und zeigen zumal unsere
Jugendlichen hier zumindest in der
Heideck sehen enttäuscht worden sind die
Wurzeln viele hat der Jungs den
Jugendclub kommen liegen in Palästina
geboren sind die meisten in Berlin wenn
sie 19 sind dürfen sie ja eigentlich
nicht mehr hin dann bleibt nur der Park
oder die Straße
und was soll ich dann machen ich habe
mir meine Jugend verbracht ich glaube
das ist der kleinste Jugendclub in
Neukölln nur zwei Räume
Tischtennis müssen wir draußen spielen
die können aber leider nichts machen
weil sie kein Geld dafür bekommen
Micky und Yasin
um die Sonne Allee ist das Viertel
arabisch dominiert auch hier findet sich
viel Armut auch hier hängen Jugendliche
auf der Straße rum fallen negativ auf
was sind Jugendliche die ja oft aus
benachteiligten Verhältnissen kommen wir
haben hier in Neukölln große
Arbeitslosigkeit
relativ viele bildungsferne Haushalte
das heißt das sind junge Menschen die
oft unter erstellten Bedingungen
aufwachsen gemeinsam versuchen sie
diesen Berliner Jungs zu helfen seit
zehn Jahren auch die Streetworker
erzählen dass ich seit Silvester nicht
viel verändert hat keine zusätzlichen
Mittel geflossen sind die Debatte um
eine angeblich gescheiterte Integration
nach den Krawallen hat sie geärgert
und wenn man von den Ereignissen von
Silvester sprechen will die aus unserer
Perspektive jetzt eigentlich nichts
besonderes waren
nichts besonderes und nicht im Sinne von
das weiß nicht schlimmes so es war schon
heftig aber ein Integrationsproblem ist
es nicht aus unserer Perspektive sind
problemlos und Männlichkeit geht und
auch wenn es Dir ganz
gesamtgesellschaftlich anguckst ist
Gewalt und Gewalt auf der Straße
männliches Problem ob im Fußball ob bei
Demonstration
ob Gewalt auch zu Hause häusliche
gewaltmännliche Gewalt Yasin und Micky
werden wir später noch einmal
wiedersehen wichtig sagen sie noch wäre
es auch die Eltern der Jugendlichen zu
erreichen der türkische Psychologe Kasim
Erdogan versucht genau dies seit 50
Jahren einmal in der Woche trifft sich
etwa seine vätergruppe natürlich ist
auch die Silvester Nacht hier immer
wieder ein Thema
diskutieren auch jeden Montag in unserer
Runde
was wir dagegen machen können
weil
alleine
Lösungsmöglichkeiten von der Politik
oder nur vom Geld abhängig zu machen das
wäre wahrscheinlich aus unserer Sicht so
kurz gedacht ein erster Schritt so sagen
sie wäre anzuerkennen dass auch die
sogenannten Problem Jungs in Neukölln zu
Deutschland gehören
das sind ja unsere Jugendliche die sind
hier geboren wir sind hier groß geworden
und für mich stellt sich halt so die
Frage warum immer noch halt von Fremden
geredet wird bzw von Migranten oder wie
auch immer diese Menschen halt in der
Jugendlichen betitelt werden und ich
habe so das Gefühl dass
wir auch versuchen das Problem von uns
zuweisen etwa als man die Täter der
Silvesternacht sofort vor allem als
Jugendliche mit Migrationshintergrund
bezeichnet habe fälschlicherweise
wir haben uns zu schnell entschieden wir
haben ja gesagt es sind so 90% junge
Menschen mit Zuwanderungsgeschichte
später hat man das relativiert dann hat
man gesagt ein zwei Drittel Menschen mit
Zuwanderungsgeschichte ein Drittel ohne
diese Stigmatisierungen während
schädlich das betonen die Männer immer
wieder miteinander reden gemeinsam
Probleme lösen das sei wichtig die
Angriffe auf Feuerwehr und Polizei gehen
derweil weiter jeden Tag in vielen
Bezirken Berlins
wir treffen Manuel Bart wieder den
ehemaligen Feuerwehrmann er weiß wie
angespannt die Stimmung bei seinen
Kollegen ist was ist natürlich einen
zunehmendes Gefühl der Unsicherheit da
das macht vor allen Dingen natürlich
auch große Sorgen wie sich das
entwickeln soll wir haben in vielen
Bereichen der Nachwuchsprobleme ein
Fachkräftemangel und natürlich eben auch
beim Rettungsdienst und bei der
Feuerwehr solche Bilder der Gewalt Nacht
machen es der Feuerwehr nicht leichter
wichtig wäre es die Täter schnell zu
verurteilen sagen und Sozialarbeiter und
Streetworker aber auch die Justiz
schlägt Alarm bei der Staatsanwaltschaft
fehlt schon jetzt Personal erklärt
Karima ruabia sie ist zuständig für
jugendliche Straftäter in Neukölln was
mir Sorge bereitet ist das tatsächlich
mehr als die Hälfte der Belegschaft in
den nächsten Jahren in Pension gehen
wird und wir jetzt schon mit unseren
Kapazitäten wirklich am Rande sind wir
haben auf jeden Fall Nachwuchsproblem
aber es liegt auch daran dass über
Jahrzehnte halt nicht eingestellt wurde
über 1.000 Fälle landen schon jetzt im
Jahr auf Ihrem Schreibtisch ohne
Nachwuchs könnte das System kippen also
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen mir macht
das Angst weil wir dann wahrscheinlich
arbeitsunfähig sein werden also es
werden dann nur noch die ganz großen
Haft Sachen gemacht und dann wird es
wahrscheinlich Verfahren geben die
einfach über viele Jahre nicht
bearbeitet werden was ja auch jetzt
schon zum Teil der Fall ist das Signal
an jugendliche Straftäter wäre fatal
würden ihre Fälle über Jahre nicht
verhandelt
zurück bei Yasin und Mickey den
Streetworkern die beiden wollen noch
etwas loswerden etwas das viele ihrer
jugendlichen besonders umtreibt
natürlich gibt es eine große Wut bei
vielen von unseren jungen Menschen
gegenüber der Polizei ähm weil es auch
dort
also weil man halt auch die Polizei
nicht mit positivem eigenen trifft
sondern weil irgendwas passiert ist und
auch Polizei oft eine Institution ist
die sehr ausgrenzen und
ja diskriminierend oft auch agiert
belegen können die beiden dies nicht
aber wir hören immer wieder von
diskriminierenden Äußerungen etwa bei
Kontrollen allerdings ist es Aufgabe der
Polizei auch mal hart durchzugreifen und
auch Sie werden fast täglich angegriffen
Problemfälle erklärt Benjamin yendrow
gebe es auf beiden Seiten das dürfe sich
nicht hochschaukeln
und da sind auch Straftäter mit da
drunter und auch Leute mit
extremistischen Gedankengut aber genau
das ist das über was wir reden die
Berliner Polizei wird nicht die ganze
Bevölkerung weil man ständig angegriffen
wird weil man eben schon auch weiß dass
das einzelne sind und eben nicht die
ganzen Bevölkerung und genauso ist es
das polizeiliches vergehen auch nicht
auf alle gezogen werden soll die bei der
Polizei beschäftigt sind weil tagtäglich
gehen unsere Kollegen tausenden
einsetzen nach und im Regelfall passiert
das auch alles ganz sauber sechs Monate
sind diese Bilder alt sie lösten heftige
Debatten aus die Politik versprache
Lösungen geändert hat sich für
Sozialarbeiter Sicherheitskräfte und
Justiz bisher wenig einige Ecken von
Köln bleiben Punkte die neue Berliner
Regierung will nun endlich konkret
handeln
[Musik]